Hey guys, Dean here, and this week we will be heading over to Boryeong, South Korea...
...where we meet a handful of humans...
...who are seeking an especially slimy kind of fun this summer.
Visitors in their millions flock to the city's annual mud festival,...
...where the aim is to arrive clean and then get as muddy as humanly possible.
As you can see, it looks both mental and quite liberating,...
...although I'm not sure if these are screams of laughter or absolute terror.
Perfect for either a romantic date or just a day out with the boys,...
...the Mud Festival offers an array of muddy memories.
These include being pushed down a slide...
...and then have mud thrown in your face at the bottom,...
...being trapped in a weird, sadistic, prisoner of war, muddy torture chamber,...
...sliding away through tiny, muddy plastic holes and even a sort of muddy rave.